ces annulations ne sont que la partie
émergée de l'iceberg
comme toutes les salles la merise a dû
baissé ses rideaux et mettre en suspend
tous les projets associatifs ou scolaire
tout le travail qui a été lancé avec
[Musique]
l'épée ac puis également tous des
travail d'amour ça avec le public
donc tout ça on a dû tout arrêter tous
copé situation identique à plaisir le
théâtre espace coluche préparer
résidence et répétitions avec des
compagnies pour la directrice ce n'est
que partie remise
j'en ai en septembre on a aussi des
projets d'action culturelle notamment
avec la compagnie käfig merzouki le ccn
de créteil qui avait commencé en janvier
j'ai donc reporté grâce au soutien du
département des yvelines en septembre
mais les salles en attente de décision
gouvernementale prévue le 2 juin
prochain regarde déjà vers l'avenir
nous sommes entrain de bridgeurs
protocole d'accueil à la fois des
professionnels qui vont venir ici mais
également du public pour le rassurer et
quoi on leur accueil dans les conditions
sanitaires au maximum au niveau sécurité
si on a possibilité d'ouvrir avec une
jauge très réduite
eh bien on fera autrement on reportera
l'esprit que tu as faim on annulera plus
rien et on à vendre à d'autres suivant
le la jauge qu'on nous autorisera à voir
on à vendre à d'autres formes on
accueillera des lectures on accueillera
d'autres événements plaisir a pu
repousser trois spectacles la merise à
reporter 95 % de la programmation sur la
prochaine saison
si l'incertitude est encore présente le
monde du spectacle n'a qu'une idée en
tête
[Musique]
m